services
yeah I got I got engaged in competitions
like this month the Xmas team I will
talk about during the presentation
so I just watch it
have this feeling
accomplishment
and thrill of organization
but but after this one I probably agree
with whatever
finally
good stuff good stuff
I'm gonna test her in my sharing my
screen and then maybe we can start in
one minute
so do you see
do you see the slides now yep yep
still seeing them
yep
okay cool
so maybe we can start what do you think
Chris
let's do it yes
super so I'm just going to do a quick
intro of idea Cyprus and then I'm going
to hand it over to Pavel
and you know for those of you that are
new here by data is a
forum and International Community where
it's a place to share ideas and you can
learn things around open source data
it's a global community so there is
there are meetups in a couple of cities
I think more than 200 you know all the
all the red dots in the the background
so it's quite a large community
if you don't know it's a community that
has been supported and organized by a
non-profit called nump Focus
non-focused is actually the organization
behind a lot of the tools we use in data
science such as those tools and so in
case you don't know it is a you know
unknown hero in a way
um and our local Meetup here in Cyprus
is uh one of the biggest meetups I think
in the island and we have around 800
members which is quite nice
we used to do it in limasso back before
kovitz but now it's all virtual and
we're trying to get back into
um
doing in the person so
um this is probably happening as soon as
you know we have a space and we're
enough people but
uh just were saying
and yeah if you want to have
a chat about the Meetup give a talk or
are you interested in you know what's
happening here in Cyprus
um
send us a message
cool I'm just going to stop sharing and
hopefully we can
have Pavel starts can you share your
screen panel is everything set up again
just a sec
foreign
[Music]
staging and then go to production and
then you have
time
have you checked the settings it seems
that it's fine
from our
just a couple Heroes sorry about that
yes
no worries
anyone else in the audience that is a
takes part in combinations like kaggle
or anywhere else
feel free to drop a message or raise a
hand
and this is to know a couple of guests
one was my teammate
several years ago
I see
I can say that I have been very
unsuccessful in competitions maybe you
know after this talk
I'll know everything that is needed
we've tried a couple of times with some
people in the company and it has um has
ended on
um an event-free
foreign
[Music]
yes awesome
let's get started
oops
okay so my name is Paul pleskov uh I'm a
senior Quantum X less and today we will
talk about uh machine learning
competitions
so why the hell on Earth I would talk
about the multiplications so I spent
more than 10 years analyzing the data in
various roles I worked in as a Financial
Consultant I did some high frequency
Trading I completed
ml events professionally for several
years also worked for several
significant Valley startups and right
now I'm working at Xmas
so I do have some experience like in
this area
so let's first Define what is uh ml
competition and what is not an ml
competition so you probably all know
hackathons uh from from the from the
like programming stuff when people uh
maybe gather for a couple of days they
work in teams sometimes they use
sleeping bags and in the in the end they
present their solution they solve some
problems so this is not an ml
competition this is a hackathon and we
will talk today about online
competitions so what's online condition
competition there are platforms where
competitions are organized uh the
duration is usually uh several months uh
it is usually more like individual work
uh so email engineer or data scientists
they build models and make prediction
predictions then they upload these
predictions uh to a leaderboard and they
they can see the placement in this
leaderboard and by the end of the
competition uh the best prediction wins
the team or individual data scientists
gets the reward
sometimes the solution is presented to
the organizers but it's not always the
case so it is a
this is kind of different from a
hackathon mostly because of the duration
so it's uh it's actually a long journey
so it
it lasts like a small project in a
company yeah so maybe up to three months
and sometimes even more
so what's uh the most popular uh
platform uh for hosting uh ml
competitions of course this schedule I'm
sure most of you probably heard this
name before so as I mentioned this is
the largest platform there are several
million registered users uh it is out
there for more than 10 years already
five years ago it was acquired by Google
and they introduced a lot of nice
features there
and this platform not only host
competitions they they collect the data
and uh it's basically a free free
service for hosting the data they also
provide free compute so you can solve
competition uh with this platform you
don't even need to use your own
computational resources so you can store
data you can compute so all the all the
features for for work is there
and uh I spend around three years on
this platform became number two in the
world number one in Russia like in my uh
popularity I was invited to give talks
in different locations all over the
world but two years ago already three
years ago I was banned completely from
this platform and we will talk about
this later
uh I I want to mention that there are
many platforms out there kaggle being
the most popular but
uh there are some local Platforms in
India in Russia in Australia they do
have less competitions for sure Less
Price money but sometimes for example
top coder is a platform uh which was
introduced by Google it was for
competitive programming in the first
place then they switched a little bit to
ml basically now they they do have two
platforms to schedule and top other and
uh like some some of
let's say professional ml competitors
they may prefer one or another platform
and I I try to to solve competitions on
all the list platforms so I basically
did a full time
let's talk uh about what the competition
is about what tasks do data scientists
solve so for several years computer
vision tasks uh like building image
models were very popular because it was
uh like there was a rise in popularity
in computer vision models uh you
probably heard maybe about resnet and
the similar models about gpus and so on
and there are different tasks in
computer division like classification
segmentation generation and so on you
might have heard the recent rise in
popularity of diffusion models about uh
it's about generated images probably
also
this crazy avatars in different styles
similar to what Prisma startup did like
five years ago now it's uh now it's
again gaining popularity so these are
the tasks in computer revision which can
be solved on during these competitions
also NLP it's not that popular working
with texts but it is getting into
polarity again right now because of
large language models and the like in
NLP probably the most popular task was
the classification task and of course
there are some standard uh things like
working with tablet the time series data
things you usually work you do at work
analyzing
numbers in the table and there are like
a minority of other tasks uh we'll talk
about so let me give you some examples
of the competitions
uh my team was successful at so first
one is a classification task in computer
vision the task was to identify which
phone camera was used to take a picture
so there was given a huge data set of
images uh there were labels provided uh
for each image which phone was used and
the task was to identify on unknown test
set on an unknown data set of images
which phone was used and the it is a
like from a
I know stranger point of view it it
seems like a really complicated task
because if you uh if you're performing a
double-blinded test you're given two
images uh you will never uh tell with
your naked eye which phone was used
which model of iPhone was used and so on
but computer vision models uh can easily
Identify some like slight Distortion in
the lens and the other features so it
was quite fun and the one of the
pecularities of this competition was
that the external data was allowed so
most of the top teams were busy
gathering new data on sites like Google
Images Yandex image images and so on and
in reaching their training data set and
basically uh the team who got the most
data one and it was our team
uh the other
really funny competition you might have
heard about this project uh
made by Google which is called doodle
where you
will uh you're given a task of drawing a
doodle on a particular
or a particular kind and then uh Google
uh trying to
say if you uh did a good job or not so
it's kind of a game and they they were
solving again a classification problem
so we had a bunch of uh Doodles uh at
hands uh there were labels
um
associated with different
classes and the task was to classify
which little this is the crocodile or a
chair or something else uh so it it was
kind of fun and we like my team won this
one as well uh the other so if you're
going away from uh classification tasks
one of the popular tasks is uh
segmentation so uh it was a actually a
company which sells the cars and uh they
have a so they need to post ads they
they take a photo of a car using
different angles and they want to remove
backgrounds that was the task uh so they
they
uh proceed with Kegel to solve this
problem uh and it was also uh much fun
it was very previous competition so as
you may imagine uh when you're removing
background uh your final score can
depend on maybe a tiny fractions a
fraction of the pixels on the edge of
this background or the car and that's
what top teams were trying to
to solve how to to cope with some edge
cases and uh maybe improve their results
uh like just tiny tiny tiny bit
uh one of the rare uh competitions on
kaggle was generating uh images uh it
was about docs so it is actually very
hard to uh design uh such competition
because uh
you have to assess the solution uh
automatically I mean if we look with our
Naked Eyes at the images it is like in
in many cases it is kind of clear if
it's a dock or not but given this task
to computer it's a completely separate
challenge
so somehow organizers solved it and uh I
mean it it was quite fun and uh as I
said uh it was a very rare competition I
I haven't heard about uh like these
tasks anymore
like in terms of uh NLP or text
analyzing there was one where you have
to normalize the text uh not the text
optimization is basically it translates
in all the special symbols and numbers
to words as a
as depicted on the slide and they were
performed in different languages in
English and Russian uh and it was one of
a kind uh competition as well and the
funny thing that this time uh there were
like top models were not ml models but
very simple heuristics some dictionaries
some rule-based methods and uh I think
organizers were kind of surprised maybe
impressed that some of the participants
included myself I didn't use ml at all
uh another text related competition uh
was
sincere questions specification uh I
think it is clear from from the from the
name of the competition what was the
task and it was uh yeah again the
classification task the fukuara this
kind of important because uh like there
are a lot of people who want to post
some questions on quora but for sure
that sometimes it is trolling sometimes
because they're relevant and so on and
they they wanted to build the system uh
of filtering uh
like let's say bad questions and uh
that's what uh the scientists and the
engineers tried to solve
uh so there are a lot of uh tabular uh
competitions like working with the table
table data uh one of the fun ones was
prediction
outcomes of uh basketball championship
in the United States uh it was made
separately it was done separately for
women's cup and men's cup uh and
surprisingly some of the models were
really robust and precise so uh in the
the the great part of this competition
was that the test so the verification of
the model was live so the competition
started uh like several months prior to
the actual games and it ended after all
the games were played so uh
we we knew the actual scores and the
best model one so it was fun as well and
uh in the other category was
traveling salesman uh problem uh in uh
2018 uh which is I think very uh very
famous among the programmers and the
people working in Funk and so on and
again there was the like in this kind of
competitions you are not expected to use
ml models but you you you may use any
kind of optimization algorithms and uh
like for ML crowd it was a kind of fun
because you have to solve uh
like uh lineal linear algebra problems
uh you use some packages you never heard
of maybe write some code in C plus plus
you probably know that all all the data
scientists use Python like almost all so
uh it was it was also fun
so I I talked about what uh tasks the
data scientists usually saw uh let's uh
maybe make a step back and discuss why
company even companies even bother to
organize competitions because for the
company it is not that cheap so if you
want to introduce your uh your task or
your competition together there is a
upfront fee fixed fee maybe around 100
grams uh it could it probably more right
now because this is the most popular
platform out there and thousands of data
scientists around the world will solve
your problem you also have to spend some
money on the prize pool which like on
average is around 50 Grand so it's not
uh it's not that that cheap to organize
the the competition so why companies do
that and the majority of the companies
do it for PR
so like uh
20 years ago every company started to
introduce uh like I.T in their processes
maybe 10 years ago people were were like
excited about Big Data everybody said we
have big data we uh and uh now uh people
like companies are doing uh so-called ml
Transformations so they said we
introduced I.T infrastructure we
collected the data and now every company
is ml company even though uh some of the
products uh are not uh ml related maybe
companies like Insurance Telecom oil and
gas but they all say that we do employ
best practices of analyzing data with ML
and sometimes they just want to deliver
this idea that uses these matters to the
world to the market to the Future in
place and that's why they organize
conditions so basically saying we are on
the same boat as everybody else we're on
the edge we do use ml it improves our
business so we are cool
uh
in like 10 of cases
it is basically a continuation of a PR
project uh companies are trying to hire
the scientists with these competitions
so if a top team wins they they may
offer a position uh with this company we
will talk about uh this a bit in a
Zillow case uh but it is a
um like direct offers uh usually array
occasion so uh probably PR strategy is
is again the main idea and that some
data scientists or Engineers are
interested in in this company they will
apply directly and there is no need to
to offer them positions
and uh surprisingly only very rarely uh
companies are actually trying to to
solve the problem at hand and uh why is
that so first of all uh during the
competition uh you don't always let's
say you never built the production
energy code so it's usually messy code
you you like do your research in jupyter
Notebook uh you don't do any CI CD you
don't do tests so it's basically a very
very vague research you may build the
model but it could be a station of like
hundreds of models so it's completely no
production radio so some of the
companies are trying to maybe pick up
ideas from your solution but uh like not
more than that so in the I mean it is
kind of a counterintuitive that
companies are not trying to solve the
problem but that's that's the case and
there's based on my experience uh my
wife also organized competitions for
several years and that that's what we
saw saw from from the company so the
motivation
so let's talk about the other side of
the coin so the competitors what
motivates them
and uh first and foremost is a skill
development so when you solve a
competition you are introduced to novel
methods you are given you're presented
with interesting tasks you can learn
from more experience experience guys and
this really boosts uh your skills and it
is really hard to find another
profession where you can like have fun
uh be involved in some competitive
gamified activity and actually
growing professionally so why why this
even like happens in the first place so
sometimes
like your tasks at work could be really
boring
um like data scientists profession is a
sexy one they do earn a lot of money but
it doesn't necessarily mean that your
life in a company will be
will be bright and fun like company
needs could be a narrowed down to some
simple models like churn or customer
lifetime value prediction which
everybody does and it's not that
exciting uh as like competitions uh
sometimes you may only work with tablet
data at your like daily activity at your
job but there are so many uh
so many new papers and ideas in
different areas like computer revision
or NLP and you want to tackle this model
you want to try things out but you just
don't have like the business need at
your job so that that's another reason
why why people stick to competitions
and the last but not least the
sometimes you you just don't have uh
like people above you to learn from so
uh a competition is a nice venue where
you can observe what other like top
the most experienced guys are doing and
pick up ideas from them and the these
Solutions are usually on the edge
of like machine learning
so this uh I think three main main
reasons why people join but it's not uh
it's not uh only not the only reasons
so let's talk a little bit about skill
development
in the I based uh it on my personal
experience so when I started to do ml
for sure I watched all the Coursera
courses uh some of you may recognize
these guys Andrew and G the the creator
of the most popular online course on ML
but the problem with the course is that
it is mostly videos and theoretical
knowledge and when it comes down to some
practical exercises like homeworks is
usually designed like for an like
average person to solve sometimes it is
boring sometimes you may find answers on
GitHub so
it's not the best way to boost your
practical skills and that that's that's
when competitions come in handy so you
have this gamification part where there
is a leaderboard and if you don't
improve like from a practical point of
view you go down and you you want to be
in the top and there is also a thrill of
maybe winning or losing and I mean there
are so so like much emotions and the
involvement so it cannot be compared to
just do the homework
and in terms of soft skills
like I mentioned in the beginning that
machine learning competitions usually
started started with individual work but
closer to the end of the competition uh
top guys usually unite in in one team
and that's when you can fully appreciate
the teamwork working from different time
zones uh maybe with people from
different backgrounds different
nationalities you may become a leader of
your team and introduce ideas you may be
a mentor to others or
uh like uh other team members uh my
inventor you if if you're not that
experienced experience so this is uh all
what I discussed maybe lacking uh on
your day-to-day job but uh you know in
the competition uh given that uh it is
very intense experience uh it can again
boost your teamwork and soft skills uh
you know Mercy
so this was uh all about skills uh and
uh like like say let's say like the
bright side there is another side of the
competition of course it's vanity fame
money and so on and uh this
this uh guy is a very famous schedule
Grandmaster
with the nickname jiba he's from Brazil
here he's been around for I don't know
maybe 10 years already he worked with
the energy engineer for an oil company
and then he started to like as many or
was did started to learn ml started to
compete he got excited got engaged
started to win and he was number one on
the global leaderboard for two years he
earned a lot of money prizes and
eventually he got an offer from Airbnb
and moved to United States with uh who
won Talent visa and this is a typical
profile of a very famous competitive
terminal engineer so there are like
maybe a couple of dozens of people of
this scale
uh and uh I mean it is hard to say for
sure what motivates them but the fame
could be one of the reasons
and uh let's let's talk about the money
so as I mentioned before like the
average price pool is usually 50 Grand
so the top team is given around 10 or 15
grand and others get small amounts but
the there were some outliers with the
some outstanding outstanding the numbers
so uh the first year with one and a half
million uh was a passenger screen in
performed by some Security Agency in the
United States so it was about
classifying images if a person holds the
gun or something dangerous
uh unfortunately it was only organized
for for United States citizens so like
the rest of all the world that did not
participate and I think the top guy he
trained maybe 100 models very very
similar then he averages them all
together so it was a very brute force uh
and the kind of a simple solution but I
mean he he sold it and like given the
lack of competition and he got the money
another case which we will cover
just in a sec more uh Zillow home value
prediction so Zillow is a company uh
which uh like may sell or evaluate or
buy houses and The
Core Business uh the core business is uh
uh pretty decent price price of a house
given the images the location all the
meta information available
and the the this competition was was
like a huge deal it lost it I think for
a year it was two stage uh two stages
competition there were three thousand
teams involved and then uh like top 100
or 200 uh went to the second stage
um they they were validated on some I
think uh maybe uh called out real data
and uh I I think top teams were actually
offered a position uh at the company and
uh went working with them but as I said
there were some consequences to it the
last one uh the data science Bowl is
like a traditional Tagalog competition
uh it's usually about some maybe more
Academia research questions uh at the
time it was about segmenting cell images
from the microscope and the I mean uh
when you see numbers like that it always
means that there's going to be a huge
competition and uh like it happened in
this case as well
so for now we discussed only the
bracelets let's discuss the dark side of
the of the competitions there is there
is always but
so first uh well it is really hard to
design a cool competition uh because
uh you need to have
like some
a data set which nobody worked before uh
you might you might want to have a an
interesting task probably business
related or uh Academia related
and uh there are very many like ideas
um how you can organize a competition
but uh the tasks are just like to to
average like to like a lot of businesses
solve as I mentioned similar tasks of
children prediction uh like still TV
models some some things which have been
done uh like uh like hundreds of times
and nobody wants to solve uh like the
status contribution and so designing a
competition it's a it's a very unique
process
uh another another thing uh so there are
usually uh like in in like in kaggle
example there is a collaboration uh
between organizers uh uh from the
company which provides the data in the
task and from the catalog team and it is
usually just uh like maybe up to Five
Guys some data scientists uh maybe leads
and uh they they have limited resources
of how like
how thorough they can be in checking the
data checking the metric
finding all the loopholes and so on and
they are competing against thousands and
thousands of top ml Engineers uh very
motivated uh out in the wild and
these Engineers they will find the each
and every
like uh Pitfall which organizers team
missed and sometimes it leads to like
conflicts and Scandals and uh
um it happens quite often actually like
maybe in every second or third condition
uh and the last but not least the
is is a also mentioned before
um competition like output models and
code they're very far from from
production and the task you're solving
uh is actually
a very limited in the scope comparing to
your day-to-day activity so you're
basically giving a metric you're giving
the data and this data is already
cleaned for you and as you may know like
eighty percent of the time of data
scientists isn't cleaning the data so
all of this work is done for you for a
competitor and you you only work on a
fun part you train the model you pick up
the architecture you fine-tune
parameters and the like you squeeze uh
all the juice out of the data and maybe
finding some insights and so on but this
is very far from Real World and
uh sometimes
like when competitive data scientists
are hired by the companies they're a bit
uh like frustrated but by by the actual
work uh they they have to do because it
is not that fun as in in competitions
so let's uh let's talk a bit about this
Zillow case
um so as I said there was a huge uh huge
prize pool
uh and
uh so it was a core part of the business
evaluating uh this house prices but
eventually it narrowed down to some ml
Ops or some uh I would say standard
practices of dealing with models model
degraded and uh the company lost a lot
of money and they had to fire almost the
entire science team even though the
competition lasted for a year I I
I put here the top of a leaderboard and
you can see that the top teams were
fighting for the fifth
and
I mean they were actually building the
best models
which could possibly be built uh but uh
like in the company they probably didn't
have a great ml like culture uh which
led to a disaster and this is I mean the
actual real case so a lot of money was
lost
and not not because uh like the models
or approaches were were bad but because
of other reasons like production related
uh one of the things which comes like
with all the competitions is called Data
leakage so it's a it's a feature which
you use in the model but it is
absolutely uh not useful in production
so to to give you some examples could be
a
some rounding issues maybe with test
data and training data could be file
change timestamp if you solve a
classification problem I saw several
competitions where people just copy
files from different folders and you can
easily separate the like positive and
negative labels based on this
information which like may give you a
first place in the competition but
totally useless in real world sometimes
you can find answers online and we will
talk about this case in a sec
so uh and that leakages happen
like quite often maybe in every second
or third competition because as I
mentioned before it is very similar to
to the work I do at Xmas we are fighting
fraud and uh when when you have a small
team of very talented very skillful
Engineers but your competition with the
thousands of highly motivated people
and you don't know what they're doing it
is very hard to win and uh this is
exactly why that linkages happen because
teamwork organizers they have limited
resources and all the data scientists in
the world who are competing uh they have
far more resources
so let's talk about my favorite topic my
ban on Kegel so uh
get your time in uh
in reading these highlights from the
media so what actually happened uh we
had a team of three people and there was
a competition uh where you had to
predict uh if
if a cattle dog will be adopted we'll go
to the shelter
and
there was a like
the host of the commission had a website
where he get the data from and the test
date as well so the natural idea was to
look up this test data from this website
which is exactly what I did
of course it was violation of the rules
uh it was basically cheating uh and uh
so we won this competition and a year
after when they were trying to implement
this model it will all revealed and so
as I said I was bent so the the price
for our team was 10 000 10 grand and
there were three team members so each
was got three thousand we returned the
money I
I made this apology public apology I
like got all these history but I really
liked how uh these headlines inflated
the prize pool because 25
000 was the entire price pool and uh I
mean it was um
it was a very very like valuable lesson
for me it was very hard emotionally
because I spent two and a half years
getting to the top at that time I was
number two in the ranking and after that
I got banned completely
um from the from the platform from the
community and so on
uh so that that was the case
and a month ago so it was it was three
years ago and a month ago uh I did a
comeback so I decided that I'm fully
recovered from uh from this event uh I
want to do things right and we entered
this trend detection challenge which was
a part of nips ml conference which is uh
one of the most famous and popular
conferences in the world and uh if you
win this competition you got the money
you write a paper submit it to this
conference you give a workshop so we
were highly motivated within it uh we
wanted to to do it right
and uh we actually did it so what was
the competition about uh it is it was a
classification task where you have to
find poison neural Nets and the poisoned
neural net is the one that
mislabel uh
in this case images if you apply some
noise or a patch to an image this is a
highly important security question for
example uh you may have heard the things
in driver's cars when people uh stick a
small patch to the stop sign and the car
doesn't stop in front of the sign so it
is a it is important in the real world
we did have some synthetic data this
competition was organized by uh
by phds and professors from Berkeley and
the other top us universities they they
had some methods which they developed
for years they had some papers and they
wanted to to see new approaches
and uh we we got the first place uh
there were several uh competition
several texts on this competition uh but
the main one was the detection just the
classification problem to separate uh uh
questions and non-pointed uh neural Nets
uh there was a really hard competition
because uh we had three completely
separate ideas which all contributed to
our first place and the final score was
uh almost perfect so we almost perfectly
separated these neural Nets and Baseline
which was provided by the organizers
separated only like in 70 percent of
cases
uh this time when we so I communicated
with organizers a lot uh we found some
pitfalls and we shared our solution
because uh at the first stage it felt
like it was too simple of a solution and
the organizers were very kind they
invited me as a as an author uh of the
paper to another conference and it was
during the competition so we actually
submitted the paper to another famous ml
competition
but there was a a lot of fun let's say
quoted upon uh from the organizers uh
side because uh uh like these guys are
really smart but they're from Academia
and uh like they they don't have a lot
of experience in organizers competitions
so people from business usually do it
better so always when you when you're
competing uh make sure that it is not
organized by Academia so there was def
there was for sure a data leak and it
was the exact date leak I I described on
one of the previous slides uh it was a
timestamp of the file change and it was
discovered by several participants but
it did not influence the results but
anyway it happened
so at some point when the competition
ended organizers decided to extend it
because one of the team
didn't make it on time and it was
outrageous I never I never saw
competition like rule like that uh but
uh I
since I I had a lot of communications
with the organizers I they reversed it
because of push from my side
there was also a problem with the test
data it was drawn from the from the
other distribution which organizers
didn't fully admit it ruined the part of
our solution but
luckily not the entire solution and then
last but not least the the pool price
was provided by FDX exchange and you
might have heard that uh if the script
exchange
got bankrupt
like recently uh but luckily organizers
find it another source of funding
so I do have a lot of materials on this
competition I will present it in the
beginning of December at excess venue if
you want to to hear more details uh come
and join it will be probably on the 7th
of December but it it will be like it
exactly also will be posted later if
you're in Limassol and want to come
offline you're very much welcome and I
will tell tell more about this
fascinating like come back
so that's basically it uh thanks for
listening if you want to contact me
these are the details and I'm ready to
answer your questions
hello
foreign
yep yep
I'm here I've lost a connection for a
bit
um
I guess I see some questions in the chat
yeah if it's possible to copy a
presentation yeah I think I can I can
give you the copy
uh no no problems here
um
what was the key idea of the solution in
recent competition
uh so there were three ideas I will
discuss the simplest one which came to
our mind so uh organizers provided us
with the Deep learning uh pipeline of
Solace competition you basically uh
upload weights of poisons and nonpoints
and uh
uh Nets then you train this huge Network
you do back crop as usual uh but it was
uh like it was computationally intensive
and uh I wanted to to do something
really simple so what we did was that we
trained
a simple ml model like a regression
model based on statistics from uh neural
net weights
so uh the neural Nets were like the
architectures were uh like fixed there
were four architectures and uh you have
all the layers you have all the ways you
can calculate all the stats like mean
standard deviation and so on and it
turned out that this very simple method
uh was
particularly useful for one one
architecture one data set
and the like organizers were completely
surprised by this idea and this is
exactly what we submitted to the paper
to I I see a letter uh
and uh but it was just one of the
one of the parts of our solution in the
if you want to learn more please come to
the muscle
but I I think we will share eventually
our Solution on the internet
and that there's going to be a paper as
well
foreign
it's really hard to design these
competitions properly
um I've never thought about that
actually
um can can you maybe elaborate a bit I
mean it's I mean it's
in my mind it was mostly you know
getting the data and arranging
everything in cargo but I guess there
are of course more to it
so you have any insights please please
sure yeah yeah
first of all I mean you do have a lot of
public data sets which everybody saw so
it's not very much of interest to
competitors you may have some data but
it could be proprietary your company
will not allow to share it with others
so maybe it should be anonymized or
things like that but even even if okay
you do have a data set and you do have a
task in mind it could be business
related you do have a metric but most of
the like
tasks can be sold very easily maybe with
automl maybe with very simple extra
boost model or a regression model and it
will not be fun for competitors to look
at this data for three months so that's
the problem so the problem is to find
the data with a lot of insights in it
and with the task related to it which
maybe was not so solved before but if
you want to do something Innovative
there is a High chance that you will
screw up so you will screw up the metric
you will optimize maybe something uh
something not related to the business
problem
it could be to like to simple over model
so it is actually and you don't want to
repeat yourself and uh like to repeat
other computations so it is actually
really hard
thank you and
um I mean are do you think I've not been
in Chicago for a while now I I gave my
choice some time ago but do you think
that the you know the competitions are
still Innovative at this point
I guess with a lot of MLP coming in and
lately I guess that that will be a yes
but probably that's the direction now
yeah yeah absolutely I think uh Kegel
always did a great job in filtering out
like the weapon ones and uh but the the
other problem here is how
computationally intensive the
competition is because with this uh NLP
lash line language models you need a lot
of gpus to be used and even uh Kegel
platform doesn't have this scale of
computational resources provided to the
competitors so
uh so there is always a trade-off but I
mean they do have more than 10 years of
experience and I think they do pick up
uh nice ones even though they this I
mean one of the pitfalls I didn't
mention uh if you don't split your data
properly uh the train and test then the
competition will become a lottery so
basically uh I mean even so the the most
robust and suitable models will probably
win but if you overfit on the like your
training data and the scene part of the
test data you will probably go down very
hard on the leaderboard because uh like
test and the train was not split in a in
a proper manner so there was not a good
uh like
specification and things like that and
that this happened several times and you
may see this final leaderboards where
people from there like they they go up
like thousands of positions so go down
thousands of positions and like people
don't like that they don't they don't
want to participate in the lottery uh
and wasting like three months of their
work but I think most experience guys
they just uh don't participate in these
competitions at all
there are many ways how you can screw up
thank you
are there any more questions from the
audience yeah do you recommend any
competitions in the near future yeah
there was a so when we finished this
present Network completion uh the same
the same organizers
had LLP competition like NLP slash time
series predicted in the future uh like
predicting the future events based on
the
text Data available at that time for
example answer the question who will be
the next United States President without
looking into the future and the the
collected the data set they published
the paper describing this data set and
they wanted to like to check it with the
competition and uh there was a huge uh
price pool of maybe half a million
dollars but it was against person by
sponsored by FTX so I don't think we
will put Spirit on maybe at the price
pool will shrink
actually not up to date in recent
computations because it was one-off my
teammate he had this dream of
having the paper on nips and we we
probably delivered his dream because
like uh there is also not finalized yet
but we should be the first uh but uh I
mean it is so emotionally intense and
they like when you're aiming for the
first place
um you you do have a lot of sleepless
nights and uh working on weekends and it
exhausts you a lot so probably
it's a good time to quit and maybe
serves of more work related her tasks
but I mean capital is usually a greatest
like they do host like competition media
every two weeks or a month and as I
mentioned there are a lot of platforms
out there just pick up like things you
you like and uh go for it
uh hi Pavel I have a quick question as
well
I was just wondering like to what extent
are you allowed to use any pre-trained
models or things like that on cargo
especially I guess for NLP tests
nowadays you have this huge
uh sets of like pre-trained weights for
language models and stuff so yeah
yeah absolutely absolutely it was always
part of the game with computer vision
and NLP
especially NLP usually data sets for
classification tasks uh even for the
core competition I mentioned there was
like it was Tiny it was maybe a
up to 100
000 examples but it's definitely not
enough to train from scratch in the for
sure everybody
uses pre-trained networks uh they use
like models from Hagen phase they
combine them together they fine-tune
them on a given their set so I mean it
is best practicing practice in the uh
it's it is exactly what you do in your
real job as well
sure thanks a lot
any more questions
I have I have one by the Light maybe
just just your also recommendation when
I I always recommend kaggle to people
when they want to learn about machine
learning and I know that I mean maybe
not recently but a year ago or something
they I cargo lodged also kind of a
tutorial series on data analysis machine
learning and so on which was is great
and but I think yeah the most for me the
most useful part is to you know take
part in the competitions see other
notebooks see the you know the the
comments in the discussion but that
would be very useful to you know to
speed you up in kind of
um let's say close to real world kind of
situations
uh but rather than you know doing a
course uh in a platform
yeah I was I was wondering what I was
going to ask what do you think about
that
yeah absolutely I support you here I
think this is one of the greatest
sources uh like knowledge and the state
of the art models and indeed their
course is great but I mean there are a
lot of nice courses out there but like
notebooks public Solutions data sets
approaches uh write-ups it's uh
especially from the top performers uh it
is just so valuable and uh there are
even I think uh podcasts or some people
doing summaries now on on the top
Solutions so we can like even the
consume the digested information and not
go like uh through all the notebooks by
yourself and maybe pick up best ideas in
some contrast form so
I mean this this is uh this is a great
place to run
thanks again
any more questions
I think it's going to be the last time I
ask then we can we can close it
all right there are no more questions uh
thank you again Pavel for for for your
time it was it was a very uh a very nice
talk
um and hopefully we will see each other
in limassolboro in another
thank you yes thank you everybody for
being here
thank you guys
thank you